[Music]
hacking is considered very difficult but
we made a cheap device that made it easy
this device can automatically hack any
Wi-Fi network even if it's password
protected to do this the attacker just
needs to be
nearby meet pwnagotchi from the words
pone and Tamagotchi this is a self-made
open-source simple and cheap device for
hacking Wi-Fi networks oh and it has a
fun digital pet inside let's see what
it's made of and how it works this video
was created by suub the verification
platform we make the digital world
people friendly yet
secure well how do hackers assemble it
themselves it's not so difficult to put
all the parts together firstly we need a
single board computer the Raspberry Pi
0w it only costs about $15 and can be
purchased on the internet we plug
Raspberry Pi into the power supply for
$19.56 then we plug the screen into the
connector on the board hogi uses an
e-link display that can be bought for
approximately
$9 unfortunately the shipping company
seems to have dropped an elephant on our
parcel in transit because when we
unpacked the Box containing the power
unit we found that the micro USB
connector and the battery connector on
the board were damaged it doesn't work
that's why we use the small power bank
to power power up our pona GOI finally
we need a fast micro SD card to put the
operating system on it at a minimum of 8
gab capacity anything for about a dollar
will be good when the hardware is
assembled we need to download firmware
from ponoi Project website and write it
to an SD card using Bina etra
program once the firmware has been
written on the SD card we access it on
the computer open the boot folder and
create a configuration file called
config
dotl in this file we will need to
specify the virtual pet's name screen
type and the names of our home Wi-Fi
networks otherwise pagi will hack
them the preparations are complete we
connect the pon GOI to the computer with
the
cable raspberry pi0 has two USB ports
one for power only and one for data you
should use the second we need to
configure the IP address subnet mask and
G Gateway for SSH access to the device
complete now just power up the pag GOI
and the device will work
automatically so you may think that this
device is like a cheap version of
flipper zero as it also embodies a pixel
art dolphin virtual pet but it's not
flipper zero contains many hacking tools
and various applications can be
installed on it and it requires button
control GOI is only made for one thing
hacking Wi-Fi networks but this device
is completely automatic all you have to
do is switch it on and let it do it all
by itself let's conduct an experiment
and check it
out to hack a wireless network even a
password protected one an attacker with
pag GOI simply needs to be within range
of the network oh a new wireless network
pwned the information intercepted by
pagi is transmitted to a program that
picks up the passwords by collecting
handshaking hashes and recovering
passwords an attacker can connect to
your wireless network they can get all
the files from shared folders and access
the internet through your channel and
access the devices connected to your
network there is also a pet rating on
the project website kind of like a
Pokémon go for
hackers
how exactly does pagi work when an
access point and a device establish a
Wi-Fi connection they exchange special
data packets called a handshake in the
WPA or WPA 2 Wireless protocol imagine
that your phone connects to your home
Wi-Fi network before it can securely
send and receive data to and from the
access point the WPA encryption Keys
must be generated this process involves
the exchange of four packets between the
client device and the access point these
are used to derive the session keys from
the access Point's Wi-Fi password once
the packets have been successfully
exchanged and the keys have been
generated the client device is
authenticated and can begin to send and
receive secure and encrypted data the
WPA handshake is transmitted by the
client in the second message of the
four-step handshake process the content
of this packet is hashed and it serves
as proof to the access point that the
client knows the psk shared key pagi
intercepts and stores such packets this
material is collected on an SD card as
pcap files containing any form of
crackable
handshake then a hash can be used to
find the password using a special
dictionary on a computer using hashcat
software or with special online services
such as online hash crack pagi uses
better cap a special tool for Wi-Fi
Bluetooth wireless hid hijacking
ipv4 and IPv6 networks reconnaissance
and mitm attacks to collect as many
authentication packets as possible honer
GOI can use two methods the first one is
De authenticating the clients if the
client device receives a disconnect
signal on reconnection it must repeat
the four-step handshake and the packet
may be
intercepted the second one is sending
Association frames directly to the
access points to try to force them to
leak the pmk ID the most interesting
thing is that the pag GOI is powered by
artificial intelligence it uses AI model
actor Advantage critic to teach itself
and enforce hacking Wi-Fi networks the
device makes funny faces that show its
mood if pag GOI said that it's bored it
must be fed immediately to do this we
need to take the pag GOI to a place
where there are lots of Wi-Fi networks
to hack the more practice it gets the
faster poni will crack new wireless
networks
pagi doesn't have any controls it works
automatically all information about the
operation of the device is displayed on
the screen the screen displays a
different
information also it shows the special
message when another person with a poni
is nearby the virtual pet can show the
different faces sleeping this is the
state the unit will start from moreover
from time to time your Pon GOI will also
perform naps of a few seconds while
hopping among Wi-Fi channels Awakening
the unit is in its last seconds of its
nap normal this face is the neutral
awake status of the unit observing the
ponoi is waiting and observing what
better cap can find on all the channels
it's hopping on intense the unit is
sending an association frame to an
access point in order to force it to
leak the pmk ID cool the unit is the
authenticating a client station from an
access point happy your pona GOI is
happy for some reason and so on the user
can customize the faces set by editing
one of the system files the device has a
fairly simple user interface by looking
at your pet's face and the information
on the screen you can tell exactly what
your device is doing right
[Music]
now so how can you protect yourself the
first first thing to look out for is of
course the presence of a suspicious
person near your equipment with a
suspicious device in their
hands use a strong network password for
your Wi-Fi and keep an eye on the
clients connected to the
network this rule can be applied to any
situation from Wi-Fi networks to your
social media and bank accounts however
and even then there is a chance that
criminals will hack into your account
and abuse it hi this is Lucas from ssup
and and today we're going to look at how
fraudes can impact businesses by taking
over user accounts say for example
you're a car sharing company many of
your clients register just for a single
ride maybe several but then forget about
their account sometime later down the
line a frauds that can get these
credentials and abuse the service in
someone else's name you might try to get
back in contact with a customer who in
reality isn't even aware of the
situation and yet all of this could have
been avoided if your car sharing company
implemented a fraud prevention system in
the first place which would have spotted
any of the suspicious activity at a much
earlier stage fraud prevention systems
can detect suspicious activity such as
unusual IP addresses new device logins
and then conduct additional checks if
necessary some sub provide such a
solution allowing companies to request
biometric and liveness checks from their
customers to verify their authenticity
if you would like to learn more about
fraud prevention Solutions and Thumbs Up
In general click that link in the
description below if a suspicious new
device appears appears on your
network this is a reason to change the
password each wireless and network
device has a unique Mac address the best
defense is to configure your wireless
network so that only devices with preall
outed Mac addresses on a white list can
connect to it this measure will protect
your network not only from the attack
described above but also from a number
of other attacks that involve connecting
a hacker's device to the wireless
network well we at suub are always here
to help you satisfy your curiosity
safely and survive in the online jungle
till next
[Music]
time